[inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible].
Hey Leanne, revamped.
There is no sheen. Leann?
Yes. Hey is pronoun and elementary. Top right king,
the most noble guys. But
if there was Shelia,
how fine,
why she might be
[inaudible]
I'm Jad Abumrad, I'm Robert Krulwich, Radiolab and today
elements.
Yeah,
I carried your oxygen and you walked beside me through the lobby commenting on
the decor when you needed to stop for breath.
Your hand ran light and steady
by the ocean of breath twice. I remember
I carried your oxygen. He was heavy.
Oblique alloy steel
[inaudible]
this hour is a collaboration with poets like the ones you heard in while you're
more of musicians, reporters,
and of course the periodic table of elements. Speaking of which,
I'm pretty sure Soren Wheeler,
who's sodium spark brain conceive to this entire show, he will lead us off.
So this one starts with a story I heard from Jamie Lowe.
She's a writer in Brooklyn.
And at the heart of this story is this particular 24 hour period in Jamie's life
that um, she is uneasy about have, let's just set it up for one second.
So what are we about to watch? I'm not actually exactly sure where it starts,
but we're about to watch, I think the night before Valentine's Day,
2001 I eventually convinced her to sit down with producer Latif Nasser and sort
of just walk us through the tape. Go for it. You're,
you're in control there with the space bar. Alright. Yeah man,
you're on [inaudible] your starts.
It's nighttime. Uh, Jamie and her friend Mike,
he's the one filming there outside his apartment in Brooklyn and the cameras
pointed at a bunch of high school students who were just walking by.
So it's a deal. So you want to be
an actress, right? Yeah, I love that.
So yeah. Really? Yeah. That's so cool. It was by any other name would smell is
my enemy though. Not a month ago. What's Montague? It is nor hand,
nor foot, nor on north face, nor any of the [inaudible]
on the camera. I'm like egging them on to recite it.
Retain the dear perfection, which she owes with that,
that title and Romeo [inaudible] name and for their name,
which is no part of the take on my [inaudible].
This isn't a part of that. Sam Screaming, um,
no wait, I load his camera eventually turns to Jamie.
She's sitting on the stoop, a huge curly hair, wide eyes,
and she starts to sing the kids a song.
It does, you know
[inaudible] right,
and we're pretty convinced that I was like a great singer and rapper.
She liked to sound a little voice. You sing a lot in. No,
never, never.
I just started thinking like that. I don't know. What was it like [inaudible]
it was fun to watch people react or she made people really happy wherever she
went.
She went to flea markets and she would talk to people and she would pull this
spark out of them. It, it just felt like New York loved her.
That's Mike Ryan Guy Holding the camera yet he'd only met Jamie just three weeks
earlier,
not long after he moved to New York and they pretty much instantly became
friends. She was so positive.
Now married, as I recall. She's talking to some little kids on a stoop,
but then that next four or five hours was pretty defining.
Yeah, by camera. Okay. Cut to Mike's apartment.
I think you're just walking around and Umbra and open dress,
sparkly red bra and plastic bag.
Plastic bag on the stomach. Belly dancing.
You might have to shield your eyes. Okay. There we go. That's boring.
Four hours.
That's my case. Sleeping. Oh boy.
Combining. It's Valentine's Day. 2001
that's come quotes and other codos the Kumquats I picked with my grandpa and
then come Quechee hope three or four days ago. And that's kind of true.
There's three breakfast bows.
What is all that stuff? [inaudible] cutting board that cut up power bars
from the president.
I gave you tidying the cup of wine that we're going to drink and a cup of wine
of course at seven 40 in the morning.
So do you need a nap or anything at noon or do you just keep pumping? Oh,
here's a dollar. Keep pouring my ink. Sure. Jamie,
what's going to happen today? Today, I'm going to contact him to,
to debate core flesh nadir or rock 10. Fidel Castro.
Yeah. He's an amazing man.
Sushil okay. I'm going to have to be about, um, can be about anything,
right? I didn't think those scientists, this one. Yeah. Fair in chocolate.
Where were you?
What were you meaning that literally that you were going to go on MTV intubate
Gore v Bush or [inaudible]
and then that is exactly what I had in mind for the day.
I thought it was make-believe. It seemed harmless.
It just didn't occur to me that what I was seeing with somebody who had deviated
substantially from who they wanted to be.
I had to change the world. Jesus Christ. Eventually Mike got up,
I had to go to work.
Jamie took off for a while and then later that day she showed up at his office
and at first everything seemed sort of fine, but within 20 minutes she said,
hey, tell you what, can we go to the roof really fast?
What?
And that immediately
got me uncomfortable. Yeah.
So, okay, over pants, flo wrap around skirt.
We are now going to the roof. Are you ready to be blown up your feet?
You can hear he is done.
Like the day has been insane. This isn't the end of that day.
Snowy seventh avenue roof type.
What do you, what does this anything,
what is that what he said? Yarn.
Mr. Bryan
tonight.
Can I have to work
on top of the world at the World Trade Center
if you want tonight.
January.
That's the end. At that point he was like done. We're done.
Wow.
Yeah. I mean,
yeah, that's when it, it hit me that um,
there is no way that any of this reflects what she would actually want.
I don't know if delusional is a kind word here and if it's not, I apologize.
But if she's delusional enough to think that we should get married,
is she delusional enough to think she can fly it?
Will she be distraught when I say no? No. And will she,
would she jump? And so I lowered the camera and I said,
I'm afraid of heights and I want to go downstairs immediately.
And I felt for the first time just fear. And I called her,
I believe I called her mother first. Leann and I just said, my name is Mike.
I'm a friend of Jamie's and um, I,
I think she may be going through something and I don't know what I'm dealing
with. I'm in over my head here.
When Mike called, I, uh,
I just got on a red eye that night. That's Leanne Lantos,
Jamie's mom.
It was my job to get her to go back to her therapist so that we could get some
medication in her for the end. This episode was not entirely a surprise.
It had happened once before when Jamie was in high school. At that time,
she was not sleeping at night, spinning around the room,
talking nonstop about how she had to save Central America from disaster.
During that first episode,
Jamie ended up at a place called the neuropsychiatric institute at UCLA and she
ended up being treated by this guy, Dr Mark de Antonio. He's a psychiatrist.
She was in a very acute, manic, psychotic state.
I remember being sort of tackled by nurses to actually take my meds because I
refused to. We didn't know if we would ever see our Jamie again. You know,
that was, that was the scariest part. Everyone around me I think was really,
really worried that I wouldn't come back.
But she did come back and it's what brought her back.
That is actually the reason I got so interested in this story.
So shortly after she was admitted, uh,
Dr de Antonio told Jamie's parents know what this is and we know how to treat
it. And he said, she's a classic case of, of bipolar. I,
there was no question, and I'm,
the drug of choice is lithium,
which is not even a drug, but just this salt.
And he's explained to us, um, you know, that she would need to, um,
take three tablets of lithium,
three tablets of the salt and it could bring her back when it works.
It's just remarkable.
Do you have memories of like what it was like to come back like that,
what you were thinking or what it felt like?
Hi. It's really hard to describe.
It's a little bit of like a slow realization of, uh,
of like, oh, that was a weird thing that I did a week ago.
Like why did I do that?
The first time she was actually lucid and coming back to herself again.
The first words out of her mouth were, mom, it's not.
Hm. And I just, uh, that just killed me
a few weeks. It
was like the incident never happened. It's so bizarre.
I mean I felt like here was this thing that's assault that I get to just take
three of a day. And, and that was it. Totally normal,
no side effects, no issues.
She went off to college and just like flourish and it was great.
Things were good for a long time. And then after about six years, she said,
you know, I've been on this pill for six years. I've had no problems.
I'd like to go off it. Why don't we try to go off gradually?
Then about a month after she was totally off lithium, she was whack
in Mike's apartment up all night. You were so tired just a minute ago.
That's cause he told me I had to leave, but now I'm still here.
ISI totally manic episode all over cause I am whatever you say I am.
That's it.
One of the things that kind of makes the lithium that affected lithium has so
spooky and you hear this from a lot of people that have taken lithium to treat
bipolar,
is that lithium itself is so simple.
Lithium is an element, right?
It's a single atom. This is Ben Lilly, he's a writer,
runs the story collider podcast.
He's had some personal experience with psychiatric drugs and he's written about
lithium.
That to me was fascinating that that a single atom can change what we think of
who we are. I mean it's not even not just Adam, it's Adam number three.
It's the third element in the table. It's one of the simplest Adam's right,
so we have these just three protons, four neutrons, three electrons.
That's a pretty simple matter. I mean it doesn't get much. It really is.
This had never struck me when I was on Lexapro or Wellbutrin,
which was the other one they put me on. You know, if you look at them,
they look like what you expect a pharmaceutical drug to look like.
There's a ring of carbon atoms and some other things stuck on that and they look
like these
big complex molecules and you're like, Oh yeah, I'm complex, my brains complex.
It takes this complicated thing to change it and then you're confronted with
just this Adam. It was found by accident that it works. You'd get,
it's not complicated to make us just assault that you distill out and yet it has
this profound effect.
The other thing I know about lithium that is that is profoundly weird,
is that you're not just saying my mind,
my personality is being changed by an Adam.
It's been changed by an Adam that was created directly in the [inaudible],
the big bang itself.
So you have this Adam formed in the big bang goes through whatever it does,
winding path to come onto the earth, gets dug up,
turned into a pill given to someone and that changes their affect in the world.
And that to me is, is just,
it's this profound reminder that the,
the forces that shape everything in the universe are the same as the forces that
are shaping who we are and what we do and, and what our identity is.
And it's possible that these forces shape not just the people with bipolar
disorder,
but all of us think it was a woman ended up talking to a clinical psychiatrist
and a fellows who told me about these studies. Huge epidemiologic studies.
Biggest one I think was in Japan, one in Austria, one was in Greece,
famous one in Texas in which they looked at communities that different levels of
lithium, lithium in the water supply, and we're talking about tiny,
tiny amounts, micro grams.
Those are a thousandth of the amount and a milligram.
If you think of like a pill of lithium,
well we're talking about amounts like 10000th of a pill.
Like that's the amount that we're dealing with here.
And these studies found by and large in towns that had a tiny bit more lithium
in than water suicide rates were lower in some cases as much as 30% wow.
I should say the Texas study,
which is Stano Xing also shows a that the towns that have the highest lithium
level have lower felonies, thefts,
rapes, and these are reputable, published studies. Nope.
These studies are, you know, only showing us correlations,
but there does at least seem to be some kind of connection and it may be if
there is a connection, what the hell is it doing? Do they know why
works in the brain? Like do they know what it does? Well, essentially no,
it's still kind of a mystery. One of them. But here's a mark d Antonio's theory
because he says,
we know that bipolar disorder involves a defect in a certain part of the brain.
It's an area of the brain that has to do with controlling mood.
So believe it or not, there's neurons in the brain that keep your mood.
Even these neurons,
they do their job by sort of passing electricity back and forth and that
electricity is carried by sodium ions.
So the whole system is pretty much based on sodium.
Lithium is very similar to sodium, so if you have lithium in the brain,
the neurons will use that to communicate.
They'll send lithium ions back and forth. And here's what's interesting.
Lithium works just like sodium but not as well.
Lithium is similar enough in properties that it can be an a posture,
but whatever does it just doesn't work as well. That's the key. He says.
So then this area of the brain,
the defective area of the brain that makes these moods flip on and off so
intensely doesn't work as well and that stops a bipolar episode.
That's so interesting that maybe it's sluggishness is what makes it good. Yup.
Yup.
Although he says that same trick where it can be a sort of sodium imposter but
slower that can also cause the issues. Slight tremors in your hand.
You can have nausea. Um, they can affect the kidneys,
the balance of sodium.
Your body is regulated partially through the kidneys and somehow lithium
replacing it can be toxic to the kidneys,
which actually brings us back to Jamie before go after that episode in New York
with Mike in the video, she went back on lithium and again she was fine.
In fact, for the last 16 years she's been completely normal.
But then a couple months ago I went to a new primary physician,
mostly because I'm lazy and I didn't want to go to the upper west side to see my
other doctor.
And this doctor basically took my blood pressure and was like,
you're gonna die. You need to go to the Er.
It turns out her kidneys were failing and so she suddenly had to make this
choice that I could sort of just stay on lithium and you know,
go to dialysis and get a transplant or that I had to switch and that now would
be when I would switch that I had enough function left that I could you have,
you are in the middle of that decision now you feel like,
or do you feel like is decided? I think I'm going to switch.
I think I made that decision.
It's just that every psychiatrist in New York leaves for August because I don't
know why, but they all disappear for August, all of August,
and mine said you should probably wait to switch until I come back.
But I, I feel like I have a good group of people around me.
I have a solid job. I,
it's terrifying to court mania,
but I also feel like there are a lot of effective drugs and that one of them is
going to work. They won't be as cool as lithium though. Depakote,
it sounds like, Oh God,
you're on Devo. Cra. As she was in the middle of that decision,
Jamie did one last thing. She actually took a trip to Bolivia,
which is where much of the world's lithium comes from.
There's this place you can go and literally see these massive salt flats,
which are just covered in mountains of lithium. Right.
I just wanted to see them. I wanted to experience them.
I wanted to be near them, so I went
[inaudible].
It just looks like a hallucination.
It looks like somebody could not have conceived of this landscape. You know,
you have red lakes and you have flocks of flamingos and this like long salty
expands that goes on for ever. Like it's just huge.
It's enormous. Do you go up to a pile and put your hand on it or, yeah,
you can. You stand on it and you jump off the pile and like, yeah,
it was makings kind of with the domain
[inaudible]
and it was awesome.
I know I have to go off of it, but I really am.
I mean, gratitude is like, not even the word. It's,
I feel like this thing allows me to be me.
It doesn't define me,
but it allows for, you know,
functionality and that sounds kind of Wonky,
but it's like every day I get to work and it's because of that,
like everything, you know, I'm just,
I'm grateful to it for it service. I feel like it's
done.
It's done a lot for, for me.
It worked so hard to get to me too. From the Big Bang to now,
uh,
producers, Soren Wheeler. Uh,
Soren is made of elements though not of lithium,
which we should say only some of which was made in the big bang.
Some of it was also made ne Supernova and we'll have one of those coming up.
Special thanks to Ben Lilly and Harrington Kay Redfield Jamison, Steve Lowe,
and of course Jamie Lo. Jamie is working on a book about her experiences with,
with bipolar. It will be called grand delusions.
This is a song from the band Sylvan.
So we played them the last story in progress and they wrote a song about it.
Okay.
Oh, space
go home.
Compassion scalp things.
Wow.
It snapped me.
Slammed Bob
[inaudible].
Wow.
[inaudible]
[inaudible].
That was Sylvan Esso with Jamie son.
Do you want to talk? Bang.
Hydrogen was there at zero hundred hours and the coke colored velodrome of dark
matter gases, checking gases at Infinitum,
chartreuse Flair, then a deafening birth ions of cosmos.
Cartwheeling Pink, red, yellow, green, purple, blue,
black and the spear of night. First I was a star,
then a stain of water, then a kindergartner.
These poems, by the way, come from the two events that we held in New York City.
We went to a emotive fruition,
which is a wonderful organization run by Thomas Dooley, who is himself a poet.
He summoned poets from all around the metropolitan area and for two nights they
came to the bell house in Brooklyn Botanical lab in Manhattan.
And so far we have heard hydrogen by Sarah Sala read by Ramsey for our gala,
helium by Christina Cantana, read by [inaudible], Abbott Pratt. And uh,
I carried your oxygen a poem by David McLaughlin, read by Sam Breslin. Right.
So next up I'm going to give you three claps. I don't know if you need that,
but just,
just in case you need to sync it. There you go. Good TV guy. Okay,
so a while back we ended up talking to a guy named Derek Mueller who makes a
youtube channel called [inaudible]
awesome, super popular channel about science and engineering.
And we call them because he's making a documentary about uranium.
And we got to talking about what happens when you take two protons or neutrons
and you just whack put them together. Yeah, it's,
it's absolutely nuts and that led to this really interesting conversation about
the beginning of all elements. I mean,
I feel like a little bit of backstory is worth saying here.
One really important thing to know is that combining nuclei gives you energy.
He says when you slam two particles together,
they get squished and in the squishing they lose a little mass.
That mass gets emitted as energy.
This is equals MC squared. That's what's happening in the sun right now.
So the sun is taking protons, individual protons and smashing them together,
combining them, and that gives you energy. The energy of the sun there.
Last mass is the sunlight that we Baskin, it was mass.
I have never thought of light as as former math. Yeah, that's what a star does.
He says it smashes little atoms like hydrogen together to make bigger.
Adam's like helium and then bigger Adams like carbon and then even bigger.
Adam's like oxygen and every little collision it's doing generates some energy
which keeps the star going.
Stars live by this process of sticking nuclei together,
going from smaller nuclei, making bigger nuclei. The heavier the star,
the more this smashing and bashing they can do in their core and the bigger and
bigger nuclei they can form. But there are limits
[inaudible]
6 million years ago that there was a star giant star whey they good than our
son. And uh, it was just doing its thing. Take an Adams and [inaudible]
smashing them together, combining
it's taking hydrogen atoms and making helium taken helium Addams and making
carbon, making oxygen. And as it's smashing all these nuclei together,
it's releasing energy and getting bigger and bigger and bigger. But then
there comes a point where sticking nuclei together no longer gives you energy in
that point is element number 26 iron.
Once you formed iron, if you're a star, that's the end of life as you know it.
Cause iron. Iron is incredibly stable.
One of the most stable nuclei in the universe.
It's protons are tightly packed in there.
And so you can't force any more energy out of them, which means you have a core,
which is no longer going to give you energy.
You can't cook up anything higher than, than the iron. That's it.
But what happens to the star? Does it just become a big punk?
What happens is everything starts to collapse.
Gravity takes over. That's the thing.
A star maintains its size by the fact that there's all energy going out to this
dead iron core starts pulling everything back in and at this point,
all of that stuff which is headed inwards, aluminum, oxygen, carbon, magnesium,
silicon starts rubbing against each other and it starts getting real hot and
real dense and all of a sudden you get
the supernova.
That was the most pathetic supernova explosion. I wasn't afraid.
Can you put in a sound effect to make that sound back?
To put it in a much like that, it is actually our specialty.
So even though we know there are no sounds in space for the purposes of your
enjoyment, we present to you
this supernova. So here's the beauty of it.
Here's the beauty of the Supernova in the ridiculous excesses of energy that are
there in the Supernova, right? In that ridiculously huge explosion,
the biggest in the universe.
There is so much energy there that actually what happens is you form these
nuclei, which would not form under any other conditions.
You know, iron hits carbon to form Germanium,
silicon hits oxygen to form titanium.
You start to get all of these bigger elements including like gold,
including the gold in your wedding ring.
They need that extreme ridiculous excess of energy to form.
And then
[inaudible] it's done.
And what are you left with? You're left with a giant field of debris.
[inaudible]
ah, there's carbon, there's oxygen, there's iron, there's silicon,
there's hydrogen, there's helium.
And it starts to clump together due to gravity.
And the center of that, uh,
which clumps together is our sun is mostly hydrogen and helium and it's like 99%
of all the mass in our solar system. And then the other chunks,
other bits and pieces start to clump together as well.
They have a bit more angular momentum.
So they're spinning around the outside and those of your planetesimals,
your early planets and,
and that is eventually how you get the earth and all of us
[inaudible] [inaudible]
this is where we caught you.
So you're saying this is the birth of everything past iron. Yeah, exactly.
Exactly. It feels like an 80 but I think I get it for the very first time.
So Post Supernova, like in the, in the milliseconds post souvenir,
you have lots. You have the whole periodic table hurling through space. Yeah,
you do. You really do.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
you can find Derek Muller most days on his youtube channel. Avera Tassian,
his documentary uranium twisting the Dragon's tail will soon appear on PBS.
It has already in fact appeared as even though already appeared on PBS.
And for some crazy reason it passed me by coming up a story that will make you
wish the Cold War wasn't over. Not me, not me. A, I'm happy it's over.
This is Hester fuller calling from the northeast kingdom of Vermont.
Radiolab is supported in part by the Alfred p Sloan Foundation,
enhancing public understanding of science and technology in the modern world.
More information aboutSloan@wwwdotsloan.org
this is Rachel calling from Fredonia, New York. Radiolab is supported by Magoo.
Shh. Students applying to college or Grad school should not have to settle for
boring, overpriced prep classes.
That's why Magoos makes online test prep for exams like the Act s a t.
G r e N. G. Mat. That's accessible, effective, and enjoyable.
Magoo students gain access to the highest quality video lessons,
practice questions and expert support at a fraction of the cost of other
courses.
Enter Promo Code Radio lab at [inaudible] Dot Com for 20% off online test prep.
[inaudible]. Hi, this is nick calling from Malden, Massachusetts.
Radiolab is supported by crystal geyser, Alpine spring water.
It starts in the clouds.
It comes down as rain or snow and then over time it passes through the mountain
naturally and finally it's bubbled right at the spring source.
Why bottle it at the source? Well,
once you've tasted that pure alpine spring water,
you'll understand why it makes sense and why it makes a difference.
Learn more at crystal geyser. pleas.com thanks.
In the moments before Charles Kinsey was shot by police in summer 2016 he
pleaded with the autistic man next to him to lie down. Please lie down.
Then the cell phone, video cuts.
I'm Audrey Quinn after effect is a new podcast from w n y c studios.
We tell the story behind the shooting and what happened next.
Listen and subscribe to after effect wherever you get your podcasts.
Next up producer, Molly Webster and Carmen.
All right. Um, okay, just for a luncheon.
Yeah. So science
and Yay. This is my,
this is my new thing with my sisters.
I just always go hashtag science cause they get really sick of me trying to
teach the kids sciencey lesson.
It's Hashtag science it. Okay.
So one of the biggest mysteries in biology is how old am I that that doesn't
seem like a mystery. Well,
I mean like obviously I'm Molly Webster who's 32 years old who has lived,
you know, through 32 birthdays I guess. Yeah. But this is a question of like,
we know that some cells in our body regenerate and so it's like how old are
those cells? Like how old is my heart right now?
Or like how old my eyeball or how old is my nose? Spleen,
the northwest corner of my kidney. [inaudible]
is this like like a m, you know, if I'm three years old now I'm 33 years old.
Do the cells in the 33 year old, are they the same as any of them?
The same as the one when I was three. Is that
the question? Yeah. That's one of the questions. Are any of them the same?
If they're not the same, then how often do they change?
Because if you understand that, then you might be able to like solve injuries,
help people heal faster or fix diseases where cells are,
you know,
messed up like psoriasis or anemia or als or something like that.
But also it just seems so cool to be able to be like, oh,
that chunk of my heart is from 1997 yes.
Or as I get other chunk of my heart is from 1983 yes. Like that.
I would love to know that at the Party of Robert [inaudible],
I would want to meet the original Robert Sells. I.
If there's anybody who's been here since 1947 I'd love to just say hello and if
you just joined me in 2015 while that's nice, I mean, right.
It would be super cool. Yeah,
so one of the questions they've had for a long time is,
is there a way that we can try to date cells?
And so they're like, well,
we can't really send anything into the body because that can be toxic.
So the answer for a long time had been no,
and then 2002 ish, this little idea pops up
and it's something called the bomb. Paul's Bom,
B. B. O, m B and then pulse p. U. L. S. E. Bomb.
Pulse. Yeah. To explain
five, four, three, two
in the 1940s and fifties we all know this. We
[inaudible]
said a lot of atomic bomb.
Hello. Huge. Wow.
The first test was in 1945 Trinity Test New Mexico. A few weeks later,
the world will note that the first atomic bomb was dropped on Hiroshima and
Nagasaki. We shall continue to use it too. Then as World War II comes to an end,
the rest of the world just tries to catch up to the u s [inaudible] explode a
huge bomb of 50 mega con the Russians.
Then after the Russians written the pliers,
its first age bought British French.
The whole cold war basically just continues
to unspool all in all over 400 atomic tests when off above ground between 19
1945 and 1963
just imagine if only one atom bomb were to be dropped on an American city,
thousands of persons would be killed instantly. It was a sucky time.
Well Hashtag Zions there's one good thing potentially one good thing popped out
and that is an answer to the question of how old are we that somehow out of the
bomb test? Yeah. How, um, let me explain, do it.
So with every one of those detonations when an atomic bomb goes off,
that would shoot a whole bunch of stuff up into the atmosphere.
All of these like radioactive elements like CCM and Tony and all these things.
But also that explosion shoots up a bunch of neutrons and the new tron will
crash into nitrogen that's floating in our atmosphere and create c 14 which is a
very special type of carbon.
It has two extra particles in it now is all that bad radioactive stuff starts
falling out of the atmosphere back to the ground.
C 14 doesn't fall out of the sky, it just sort of floats there.
And what happened is over time the wind currents carried c 14 from these test
sites and just spread it all over the planet.
And this sea 14 which is just totally like normal carbon,
non harmful,
it just bonds with oxygen and it gets sucked up into plants.
And then animals eat the plants and then we eat the animals or we eat the plants
and then suddenly the scene 14 is in us. Huh.
So we all have like a little bit of the atomic age in us way that I wasn't even
born in 1963 so w why would it be in me?
That is the cool thing because it hangs out in the air for a long time. So it's,
it's actually still up there. Hmm.
But why does this have anything to do with dating? Anything? Yes.
I'm about to tell you that. Hey, are you there? Hi. Yes I am. Yeah. Yeah,
her thick.
I'm Bruce [inaudible].
I'm a senior scientist at Lawrence Livermore national lab.
[inaudible] professor of stem cell research at the Karolinska Institute in
Stockholm.
So in the early two thousands [inaudible] staring down this question of like,
how do I date cells?
And at a certain point he gets together with Bruce because he comes up with this
idea, which is just, Oh, maybe we just look up.
So Derek,
there are some groups in Europe and there's one in particular that's been
measuring the atmosphere every two weeks since the late 1950s it's an incredible
data record.
Bruce says,
what the scientists have done is they've taken all of these measurements and
they put them into one chart.
So you can see the amount of see 14 in the atmosphere over time.
So we, we have this basically a basically a calendar and I could,
I could send you a picture so you can see what, see what the graph looks like.
Yeah, I'd love to see a picture. What you see on that graph is this,
according to Uranus, up to 1955
so pretty flat line with very little variation can suddenly in 1955 with all the
bomb tests,
there's a very sharp increase,
a lot of carbon 14 very drastic increase. That's why they call it a pulse.
That increased goes all the way up to 1963 when Roman portraits of Communist
doctrine is a tearing Auburn's doric event in the u s the UK and Soviet Union
agree to stop exploding atomic bombs above ground signing of an Adam test
ban.
After that,
there's a gradual decline and you know,
they're just measuring it all the way down so they can just say, oh,
like here's where it was. And Yeah,
seen 80 years where it was in 99020002010 this right here is the coolest part
because the amount of [inaudible] in the atmosphere at any given moment is
directly reflected in ourselves. Right. So if there's like
h c 14 in the atmosphere in September,
1972 yeah.
Then that is
going to be mirrored in cells that were born in September,
1972 so it is like this totally perfect birthday calendar.
We can see approximately how long have they been there for 10 years or 20 years
or 30 years. It's like once this idea got out,
every like scientists all over the world were like, Oh yeah,
oh give me your attention. There's been the new invention.
It didn't take long to see that this might be something cool to do
came about because they made a big atomic bomb.
So just to give you a quick sense of some of the work that came out of this,
I spoke to one scientist,
I'm Kirsty Spalding and I work at the Karolinska Institute in Stockholm.
She was working with Yoanis and they figured out how to use c 14 in brains.
I mean, first of all, the basic question was can adult humans make new neurons?
She says that for like a hundred years,
the dogma had always been that the neurons were born with other ones we die
with. The problem was she had no way to investigate this.
She couldn't use it in humans,
even if they were dead humans until she figured out a technique where she could
like extract brain cells and see how much the 14 was in there. Yeah, exactly.
It turns out the next best thing to human is a horse because horses can live for
quite some years, decades.
So every second Tuesday I would go out to the local Avatar,
the local slaughterhouse an hour away and I mean I was a vegetarian surrounded
by caucuses where they would bring the horses head out to me and I had to figure
out how to get the brain out of its head and what you actually had to like cut,
open the skull and get to the brain yourself.
I mean the second time I went I took my boyfriend with me cause I was like I
can't do this.
Physically they actually had a circular saw and I actually discovered that the
the skull, the bone across the top, the nose of the horses is quite thin.
So that was a much easier access point. This is really gross discussion.
Did you ever see your research going that way? No, absolutely not. Not at all.
But what she saw when she finally moved her research from Horseheads to humans
was turnover. We found quite robust levels of new neurons in adulthood
can get, why do I take,
once the onus is team show that this worked,
scientists got excited and people to date things and not just cells.
So can I tell you the ages? Sure. Okay.
The baseline age is,
we knew before seat 14 was that skin was like 14 days old.
14 Ford Olf only 14, 10 days. Yeah. So like two weeks.
Um, the surface level of your gut, the like the skin on your gut,
I guess was five days, five days.
That's even shorter than skin does. That's like the surface of the intestine.
Oh, the surface of the, yeah, the line. The lining.
That's cause that's everything. Scraping all that food going down.
So though that doesn't surprise me. And then with sea 14,
the deeper muscly part of the intestine,
the average is 15.1 years.
15.1 years old.
Big Difference Between 15.9 15.9 years old. Point nine years.
Fat Cells was another one that they did a 10 years old.
10 years old. Yeah. Interesting. Why would a fat cell need to last that long?
10 years. She says
[inaudible] cells. You've been, honestly, you've David, did they have any idea?
They don't know. Huh? Did they know that?
Like what would be one of the oldest part of us?
Your um, your Cortex, which is, uh,
like the part of your brain that does like abstract thinking or your voluntary
movements. That's as old as you are. Really? Huh?
So if you wanna know one of the oldest parts of you,
the oldest cell is probably in your, ah,
part of your brain. It'll be like your cortical neuron will that fits?
If I think of myself as the stories I tell myself,
like when you get Alzheimer's and you lose your stories and you lose your mind,
they people say,
but the interesting thing though is the hippocampus is where you keep all your
memories and they saw that your hippocampus does make a bunch of new neurons in
the hippocampus. That's Yunus Friesen. Again,
the halt gets approximately 1400 new hippocampal neurons per day.
Really? Yeah. And then each of those neurons will live like 20 maybe 30 years.
So does that mean that the part of Robert's brain where he keeps the stories,
he tells himself that part is being made new every 20 or 30 years? Yeah.
It's a strange thing that like your oldest stories could be stored in baby
little neurons. It is weird. Yeah.
I remember going to Kyoto and it's like the oldest most beautiful temple in
Kyoto.
It has exactly the form that it had, you know,
hundreds of years ago.
But when you walk in the the walls and the floors and the roofing and they've
been restored,
they've been restored actually over and over again because in Japan what they
call old is the form. It's the shape of the building.
You go to happens though,
and you go to the Acropolis and you stand in the Parthenon there you're standing
in the very temple that para clis stood in. It's the same place.
Exactly. Same materials, so I can,
in Greece they believe that the original stuff is the,
is what you preserve and in Japan they don't, they think it's just the form.
And I was thinking of this thing you're doing is sort of a little bit like that.
Like I,
I was thinking I'm much more Greek than I am Japanese because I want to know
like what my original cells are. If they are where they are in me.
Yeah. But my question is, Maxine meant more basic.
It's like why does part of me get to re reborn in the other parts of me don't
like why not all of me get to be reborn? Because if all of you is being reborn,
you would just crumble into dust.
Nobody to be quite as white is only certain parts get to regenerate.
It's interesting because they don't know. They said the next,
they said basically this question of how old is a cell?
They said no one was asking. Everyone wondered this,
but no one was asking this question because they never had the tools to ask it.
So now they're just starting to ask those questions. It's,
but there's a problem.
Okay.
This balm pulse that we've been dependent on in the last decade to start
answering all these questions is going away.
Really every day a little more of that c 14 gets sucked out of the air.
How much time do we have left? 15 years. It's gone by 2030 give or take. Yeah,
so we need to get questions answered now because we really are working against
the clock for many things we want to look at.
I talked to this Alzheimer's researcher who was trying to figure out like the
chronology of the disease,
like when certain like pathologies form in the brain and he was kind of just
like, I just wish I had a little more time
[inaudible]
and when I think about this, thinking about this on the subway this morning,
like I was looking around and I was thinking, you know, I'm on the l train,
it's a bunch of like 30 year old kids or something and has like these,
they're all reading or something drinking their expensive lattes and like these
people are so far away from thinking about the Cold War or atomic bombs or
anything like that and they're all walking around with like the secret signal
from the atomic period inside of them.
And then that little signal is like binging out like knowledge about
their shoulder and their elbow in their liver and the west side of the liver and
the east side of the liver and like different parts of their heart and the fact
that it's now going away. And how like someone born in
too is just going to be really boring. And like,
we know they're not going to have any insights into who they are,
which sort of makes me inclined to very peacefully want to [inaudible]
explode another atomic bomb. What?
No, no,
no one know why you forget all the poisons that that is not a benign event.
That's sort of an experimental picker upper that is extra extra stuff
on the air. No, my dream. I have to kill your jingle. Dumb dumb dream.
[inaudible]
[inaudible] red. No.
well [inaudible]
[inaudible]
do you want [inaudible]
um, they don't tell me. Tell the phone. Well then no man knows as
[inaudible]. Uh, this draw
[inaudible] are known by God. No
[inaudible]
producer Molly Webster and special thanks to Henry [inaudible], Mark Lovell,
happy Valentine's Day. Magnesium.
I'd go blind watching you burn magnesium.
Iodine is cute the way it sublimated and yes,
I'll put lithium in water to watch it's scoot about,
but my heart belongs to you. Magnesium,
the hot white flame,
the abandoned the slowness of you becoming your own fuse.
Mercury is beautiful. Yes, but it's you.
Magnesium.
Yeah.
The way you burn from me, the way you leave,
nothing of yourself behind.
We are flying over Greenland. Yeah,
elbow is too close to mine on the airplane armrest down there.
They are excavating uranium from beneath the Arctic ice and selling
indiscriminantly.
Though from here I can only see the white tub ice sheets in glacier topped
mountains.
This is an island of fishing rigs and colorful houses,
cod and cat fish stew and tomato cream.
Once I thought every isotope in me is radioactive.
I make the people who love me sick.
This is a teenage way of thinking,
but you have uncovered a glowing spark in the pristine frozen places within me.
[inaudible]
that was uranium from poet Emily Hockaday read by Joanie's, Abbott Pratt,
and before that happy Valentine's they magnesium by Jason Schneiderman,
by Sam Breslin.
Writes really as a middle name in this thing, so they didn't, right. Yeah. Okay.
Come on up. We're gonna get into an elevator, push the button and go down.
And I mean all the way down. I'm Robert Lewis Call,
which Chad Nicholas. I've boom rod. Yeah, we'll continue in a moment. Hi,
this is [inaudible] Castro from Bogota, Colombia.
Radiolab is supported in part by the Alfred p Sloan Foundation,
enhancing public understanding of science and technology in the modern world.
More information about Sloan at www dot [inaudible] dot org [inaudible].
Hi, this is nick calling from Malden, Massachusetts.
Radiolab is supported by crystal geyser, Alpine spring water.
It starts in the clouds. It comes down as rain or snow,
and then over time it passes through the mountain naturally and finally it's
bubbled right at the spring source. Why bottle it at the source? Well,
once you've tasted that pure alpine spring water,
you'll understand why it makes sense and why it makes a difference.
Learn more at crystal geyser. pleas.com thanks.
Hey, this is jad. Radiolab is supported by rocket mortgage by quicken loans.
Chances are you're confident when it comes to your work, your hobbies,
and your life.
Rocket mortgage gives you that same level of confidence when it comes to buying
a home or refinancing your existing home loan. Rocket mortgage is simple,
allowing you to fully understand all the details and be confident that you're
getting the right mortgage for you. To get started,
go to rocket mortgage.com/radiolab equal housing lender licensed in all 50
states and m l s consumer access.org number 30 30
hey, I'm Jad Abumrad. I am Robert Grill, which is radio lab and today.
Okay. Elements. We're doing it.
We're doing it.
[inaudible]
satirist, Tom Lira.
[inaudible].
Okay, so we have this periodic table of elements, which is
a list of the simplest bits of matter that we know of. And so theoretically,
everything that we see, everything that we are made of,
the stuff that is in that table,
that's sort of the beauty of the periodic table is that it describes everything,
right? Yeah.
Yeah. About 45 years ago,
a scientist named Vere Ruben was studying the motion of the galaxies.
You know how the geology is just spinning in a beautiful way around like in
spirals and her calculations did not explain why the galaxies were holding
together and she figured, nope, there's be some stuff
that I can't see around the galaxies that explain why they moved the way they
do.
What is that stuff? Whatever it is,
it's not interacting with the matter of our world hardly at all.
Otherwise we'd see it. It's indeed while we call it dark
[inaudible]
dark matter is the dominant, uh, uh,
component in the universe.
That's experimental physicist Rick Gaitskell did the,
the stuff you and I made of the, you know, there's these conventional protons.
It's the flotsam and Jetsam ultra matter. Well it's,
it's cost on a sea of dark matter.
We're talking about in terms of the total composition of the universe,
you and I, the stuff we made office four and a half percent,
the other 95.5% is this stuff that dark matter, dark energy,
which theoretically is all around us. If you cup your hands,
you have a dark matter particle in your hand, the brawl blow mold.
The challenge is that it is so weakly interacting that it will pass straight
through you.
And in fact we'll pass straight through the earth bed and will have very little
probability of interacting.
But what if you could get one of these little best or sit interact
then,
I mean forget to be like table,
then you would meet the most fundamental element of them all city as lead a
store comb town.
We're going to tell you about an experiment now and this is our experiment and
we sent our producers, Andy Mills and Dameon Marchetti a check it out, right?
Do you think it's, this close is happening in South Dakota, in the black hills,
in this little town called lead.
And I have not seen this many trees and so incredibly beautiful picture,
this little town, but right near the town as you crest over this hill.
Oh, that's a deep cut.
You'll see this mountain that looks like it's just been torn open.
No,
we uh,
we pulled over and we walked over to the edge of this thing and it was like
peering down into an ancient volcano.
That's not what I thought it would look like carved out that ill in this town,
there is one of the deepest manmade holes on the planet.
That's where the experiment is and it's there because way down deep in that
hole, it's demonstrably the quietest place in the universe.
Okay.
That is Ken Myers. He's a writer.
The quietest thing will make sense in a second.
He wrote an article in Harper's magazine recently that is all about this
experiment and this whole,
I was interested in the idea of of these frontiers at the, you know here,
where are you from frontier? I'm from Minnesota. Oh, there you go.
People tell me I sound like I'm from, from the movie Fargo. Let me join them.
Anyway, Ken says that this
story, it starts off way back in the old way.
Saw Hardy Bronte, wild, rugged,
1874 general Custer and crew Custer comes out looking for this gold and finds it
gold on the mountain in the rivers and in the dock are below the surface of the
earth and just like that,
10,000 people within two years are just invading illegally invading the black
hills, which were the great Sioux reservation, and by 1901 the miner's blast,
1,500 feet down by (927) 300-0500 feet down by 1975
it's 8,000 feet deep. To put that into perspective,
that's a sort of mile and a half, but usually a mile and a half,
they literally move mountains. Oh, it's a mess. Yeah.
Imagine six empire state buildings going straight down and gold.
Is that valuable that you could put that kind of effort and energy?
Isn't that astonishing? Yeah,
but what happened is that eventually the price of gold dropped to the point
where the size of the mine was just unsustainable.
When you're mining 8,000 feet down, you know, for every foot you go down,
your price increases, your costs increase. You've got to haul it further.
You've got an air condition, the mine,
you've got to pump out the groundwater and you'll have to run electrical lines
down there.
You've been so in 2001 after 126 years of being an operation,
the mines shut down. Did it create a ghost town? I mean did, this was the fear.
This was the fear that we were just going to have a whole,
the whole economy of this part of the country was going to fall apart.
But as this was happening,
we saw an opportunity though these physicists realize that this was a a golden
opportunity. Limited it before we,
I don't remember like how I do physicists do fair mental physicists cause they
love holes traditionally. Yeah. They're just in love in halls.
They just like dwarves. This is where we get to that idea of quiet,
this experiment.
It needs a kind of quiet that you cannot find on the surface of the earth.
When you and I are sitting on the surface of the earth,
we're not acutely aware of it, but we are
being hit by cosmic rays.
At a rate that I think really rather amazes people,
that if you simply hold your handout three or four times a second,
cosmic ray is going through your hand and it's going right through it.
And that's every second. Uh, so your,
your body is literally bathed in thousands of these.
Every second we are just being bombarded with,
uh, IDN.
Rick Gaitskill talks about it like being in the middle of a stadium during the
super bowl.
And this is as though everybody in this arena is clapping.
Now just imagine that in the middle of all this chaos,
there is one person leaning over to their and whispering
a secret into their ear. Dark matter is like
the whisper.
It will be lost in the noise.
We have to cut out all this noise in order to even come close to hearing it.
[inaudible]
and
it turns out putting a mile of rock between you and the, uh, is,
is taking you a lot of the way that [inaudible]
yeah, it's a great sound.
So Rick took us into this mind through these massive iron doors down these
woo
long underground tunnels.
[inaudible]
into a room where we met this guy. What's your name and who are you?
Mike Sunni is grew up in lead South Dakota.
I'm the fourth generation that's been hanging around and the Homestake mine.
Mike worked at the mine, so did his dad.
Both my grandfathers were Homestake veterans. Uh,
most kids that Mike went to school with and his dad went to school with.
They worked at the mines and my grandmother's father on my dad's side was also a
minor,
but now,
now he works in a room where he basically equipped scientists with other safety
gear and stuff. He gave us these boots and a respirator.
Catch on fire. Do you want to be able to freeze?
That's what you want to hear it in the morning and eventually over
the climate and this old steel surface elevator, a little farther
south cage of the 41
Laura south cage, and then
you just start rocketing downward.
Plus you're going so fast.
The speed at which we're moving instead of equivalent to the speed at which an
airplane often, you know, when it's descending at a thousand feet, our ears pop
2000 feet. This sort of wet, muddy smell sort of walks up
and as we're dropping, all that noise is getting
slowly.
We're able to literally use the Rock, uh,
to absorb these cosmic ray particles. After about 10 minutes,
elevator stops. Hello.
Thank you guys. Thank you.
And we step out 4,000, 850 feet down.
This is a cave man. It looks like a cave.
It's got, um,
a dome like ceiling and walls that are just carved rock.
What does that sound? It's water.
That's the sound of rain coming through
a whole lot of rock.
To be clear, it's not raining outside. It's not ready to go up in the world.
It's just groundwater. According to camp,
it's costing over a million dollars a year just to run the pumps to drain that
water. So that gives you some, $1 million a year. Yeah.
But Rick says down here like this is the least amount of radiation that we will
ever experience in our lives. It is quite dramatic.
It's about 3 million less a cosmic rays.
So when you hold your handout less than one every few months,
January
coming through your hand now
march. [inaudible]
but that isn't, that isn't the end of the story.
So we're going to step inside here. The very first step,
we actually even have an ice and the other doesn't.
It turns out that even if you cut out all the rays coming from the outside
there, still raised coming off of us, you and I,
we carry us out in the amount of uranium and thorium,
these radioactive elements in us. So,
okay. So what we're going to do is you're going to take your cover off,
saw a woman named Robin Barlin, made us change clothes. Oh,
can you take that machine out? Yeah. Scrubbed our stuff.
Oh, the microphone. I'm gonna wipe this. That. Okay. Yeah.
And then Rick takes us into the lab where the experiment happens.
It's this all white room with this huge tank in the middle. The, uh,
tank, uh, contains 70,000 gallons of high purity,
uh, water and was w w you know, directly inside it.
And we can without fear of disrupting experiment one cut. And, uh,
the experiment actually happens inside this day.
I'm going bang the outside of the, uh, the steel container.
The whole idea is that
this water will actually filter out even more radiation that makes it very
quiet, but still it's not quiet.
And so inside that tank of water,
they put an even smaller tink of the element xenon,
about a third of a ton of liquid xenon.
Where do we find xenon on the periodic table? Where, what is it?
So you don't want this number of 54, 54, it's over on the right hand side.
So that, that we have this, uh,
imperially named a set of elements we call the noble elements. I mean,
they're just too good for everybody else. They interact hardly at all.
That's right. You really struggle to make xenon interact with, uh,
with any other atoms,
which is just another way of saying that inside of this tank of Xenon,
which is inside of this tank of water,
which is down in one of the biggest holes ever dug by man,
it is really, really, really, really, really quiet. It's demonstrably the,
the quietest place in the universe. I mean you can't, you,
you don't know that it is because there could be somewhere, some quieter place.
But as far as we know that the center of this lux detector is the quietest place
that we human beings know of and what's supposed to happen inside this super
quiet xenon space.
So the idea that you have here is that this cloud of Zenon,
it's just waiting.
And the thought is that when a dark matter particle,
that's like zooming around all the time when that zooms through this [inaudible]
because it is so quiet in there because there is nothing else happening in
there. That dark matter particle,
even though it's not supposed to interact with anything from our world,
that particle, if it disturbs, if it nudges in any way,
any of the atoms of the xenon will notice it and that tiny little disturbance
whenever it happens. Ken says, you can think of that moment
as the universe whispering to us,
the whisper and human nature though the whisper is a point where we really,
when we really want to speak intently to a single person,
we whisper when, when you know, we whisper at funerals,
we wish for in the presence of awesome things in nature.
We we,
you know, it's sad. It's sad,
reduced use of the voice that drops down and drops down to,
it only goes into the ear it's intended for. It's,
it's Isaiah's call, you know,
he's lying on his mat and he hears the whisper because he knows that's for me
alone. That call is for me alone. And that's,
that's that sense that this experiment gives to me is that here the universe has
been shouting and shouting and shouting and shouting at us.
And we've gathered all this scientific knowledge out of the shout,
out of the clapping, out of the cheers.
And now where we're at in the 21st century is,
is we're quick going down to what's it saying in the whisper.
And those whispers go clear back to conception. They had clear back birth.
If we understand these whispers,
we're very close to understanding
just station and, and [inaudible]
I got carried away there, but oh, we love you. Really. Yeah. Okay.
And did you get to hear the whisper, see the disturbance,
whatever it is, did you meet the dark matter? Well,
how can I give this to you lightly? Okay. So this, this is confession time.
I've,
I've been looking for dark matter for 27 years and so far we have yet to see a
convincing set of uh, interactions that are Stacey with this dark matter.
And that's nothing at all. Yeah. Nothing bucks.
Rick hasn't given up hope a, I mean he sort of never gives up hope.
I mean he says maybe we just need to build a bigger, more sensitive detector.
That's of course exactly what we're doing instead of their current one,
which has a third of a ton of Xenon,
we are now designing and building a detector that's going to be a 10 tons.
You see it says even there, who knows. The uncertainty we have to deal with is,
is, is at least a factor of 10 million,
10,040.
The other 25 pretty disappointed thing is that when you're in this room,
like in the room with the Lux detector,
that's supposed to be the quietest place in the universe. It's loud. It's crazy.
Louder.
There are sounds that I can only describe as robots dying.
Like, listen to this.
Was there any moment that was quiet? Like quiet? He quiet like deep, quiet,
fairly quiet.
Well [inaudible] sort of
after we, we went to the Lux, we had some time to kill and um,
they took us into the raw part of the mind where it is to mine for gold. And,
um, they just sort of walked us through these, oops. The huddles. He's scared
a little bit. Yeah. And you're,
you're walking through the black and all you hear is like the sound of our feet
crunching,
the wind is being sucked down. It's kind of rushing through Thomas. Yes.
And it's the silence. It's, it's not like, it's not like the science of like,
oh, the street is really quiet outside of my bedroom.
It's got like an energy to it. It's like I got, it's got like this room.
Mm.
It's kind of like when you're running and when you stop running and the absence
of your exertion sort of fills you. Yeah.
It's like that moment where the absence of the noise sort of becomes palpable.
And that's, for me, the moment not standing in the laboratory. For me,
that moment was the moment where I'm like,
now I am standing at the center of the xenon.
I don't think I ever, ever have felt that before.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
producer, Damiano Marchetti and Annie Mills,
we have had Damiana with us for almost a year and it's been a total pleasure.
He is moving on. But we wish him,
what are you going to wish him and wish him quiet? The good kind of quiet,
you know, the kind that has energy. Oh, that's nice. You know the wool walk guy,
that guy. Thank you. Damiano huge thanks to Thomas Dooley.
We had original music this hour from one through six point, never sylvan.
So Kevin Drum,
Ken Campton and VJ iron to Matt capus and to Connie Walter and to the folks at
Sanford underground research facility for letting us visit them and stay and
stay and ask so many questions and finally leave. Yeah.
Which is what we're about to do. I'm Jad Abumrad. I'm Robert Krulwich.
Thanks for listening.